hello today we're going to look at
efficient streaming language models with
the tension syncs by researchers of MIT
meta and Carnegie melon University this
paper proposes a pretty simple idea to
solve a problem that exists when you try
to take a generative large language
model and just let it run forever uh be
mainly beyond the window that has been
trained on so if you want to
continuously let such a model run you
either have to do some tradeoffs in
order to make that fast or you have to
do a lot of
recomputation uh in order to keep its
quality up but you can't really have
both and this paper investigates this
and discovers that there's an
interesting property with any token
that's kind of at position zero during
pre-training and that serves as a
so-called attention sync which kind of
keeps the attention scores and the
softmax distrib distribution stable and
y y we'll get into it what it what it
does but the end effect is that this
paper delivers an a more efficient
method to let language models run beyond
their initially trained context window
and not suffer any performance hits
either in speed or in perplexity from
that so what is the problem the problem
is the following let's say you train
with a attention you train a language
model with an attention mechanism and
this these squares here are what they're
supposed to tell you is how does that
work as your sequence gets longer and
longer and longer so we'll go through
one here so you have a few tokens token
token token token token token and let's
say you have a pre-trained uh language
model uh that you now run inference with
so the first token these are just slots
by now the first token just attends to
itself all right the second token
attends to itself and the first token
the third attends to these two and so on
until the last attends to like all all
of the the previous ones that's why the
what we usually call the attention mask
the causal attention mask is a lower
triangular Matrix where it essentially
says okay the first
token only attends to itself where where
how is
that how do we read this oh maybe here
the first token only attends to itself
so one attends to one and then the
second token attends to the first and to
the second and so on maybe that's the
way to read it let's see we'll figure it
out when we get there the problem is
obviously that if you want to if you
want to run inference now on another
token right here uh this at some point
you get to the limits of your memory of
what your memory can handle as you all
know this thing here has quadratic
complexity and therefore going Beyond I
don't know 4,000 8,000 tokens nowadays
is just kind of beyond what the hardware
can do and also it's not trained for
that so you can do something with
positioning codings but usually once you
go beyond the context window of training
either your Hardware blows or the model
is not trained for it and so on so
that's just kind of a nogo so what what
you have to do when you want to just
keep running inference here there are
there's a an easy way which is let's
let's just if I want to it run inference
in this token let's just only consider
essentially this here to be the previous
sequence so forget about this token
let's only consider these ones and now I
caner this one and then let's only
consider these ones and then I can infer
this one right so it this sort of
sliding window to look back on almost
like a recurrent neuron Network in in a
in a way so this actually works this
works pretty well um and this paper says
yeah this works pretty well what's the
problem the problem is performance
namely speed so see what you can do when
running inference in these models is you
can build up a so-called KV cache or key
value cache however you want to call it
but essentially the principle is this
since let's say the third token only
looks back at these two tokens in all
the layers right you have many different
layers in your Transformer but no matter
what layers because of the causal
attention they only ever look back that
means whether you inference the 10th
token here or the 15th they can look
back at stuff you know that was previous
but that third token
here can only ever Look Backwards okay
so even even if I inference a token down
the line right here through the layers
it's never that I have bir directional
attention I only have unidirectional
attention now that's that's kind of a
flaw of these GPT style Transformers and
we do it so we can train them more
efficiently because if this one it's
totally conceivable that if I inference
the 15th token right here that in layer
one this token could actually let's say
this token in the next layer could look
could put some attention on the 10th
token here right and then in the next
layer the 12th token could put some
attention here and then in the next
layer the 15th token could put some
attention here that's totally
conceivable from a from an algorithmic
perspective the problem is um I can't
train this efficiently I have to train
each token separately whereas if I
restrict my attention to only ever go
backwards no matter what right then I
can essentially use each token in a
sequence as a as a training example so a
15 token sequence gives me 15 training
examples at the same time for free and
that's the idea behind uh behind using
causal attention and because of that
whether I in inference the 10th token or
the 15th
token that third token is only going to
look at the second and first token and
also these they they remain constant so
all the computation in all the layers
I've done for this essentially remains
constant from here on out and all the
computation of the fourth token
essentially remains constant from the
fourth token out and so on so I only
actually ever have to compute the all
the layers of the new token I want to
inference because that can surely look
at all the tokens previously but none of
the past tokens are going to change
anything because they can only look back
and so you see you can c cash all of
this once you've run the inference for a
token you can cach all of it through
time now this breaks down as soon as you
do what we mentioned above here so as
soon as you drop out that first token
what happens well look at this third
token right here it it based its own you
know computations upon looking back on
that first token now that first token is
no longer there so its computation is
kind of wrong because we now say only
this here is our new sequence and
therefore this third token which is now
the second token could can only look
back at this token right here and
nothing else so we need to update its
computation because the past is no
longer the same and therefore our
Assumption of we never have to update it
again is invalid and that means we have
to essentially recompute all of the
tokens here for every every single step
because in every single step we're going
to modify the past by one token which
invalidates the cache for everything
that comes later and that is the
conundrum right here we can do this
sliding window attention um however we
will in order to make correct
computations we will have to
recompute every single time um the the
essentially the entire attention you
know the entire attention Matrix and so
on um yeah and that's kind of slow
that's much slower than keeping it all
in cash so what people have done is they
simply said screw it screw it we will
not recompute we will just keep the
we'll keep the caches here you know
these this token it just keeps its cash
um and it we'll we'll just deal with it
right it's it's even more beneficial
because it's kind of as if that token
could still look back even though that
that stuff is no longer in context if we
keep the cash around it's kind of like
you know it gets that information right
now and then the
only issue is that this new token here
can't look back at the first token right
that's going to be the only information
path that's blocked but keeping the cash
around essentially is like you know we
as far as this token is concerned we
still have that those old values in
scope but not as far as the new token is
concerned I hope that explains it like a
little bit so if we if we keep the cash
just if we don't keep the cash around
then the third token can only look at
the second token no longer at the first
token and also the 15th token can only
look at the second the third and so on
token and no longer at the first token
however it's internally consistent it's
like this is a sequence right and within
the sequence it's entirely consistent
it's just that you know you you don't
see further back than your length when
you keep the cash around it is as if the
second and third token could still look
back onto the first token however only
the new the 15th token is now blocked
from looking back at the first token
which is apparently a problem so what
this paper says what this paper proposes
is if you do
this it doesn't work like if you do this
um you'll suffer terrible terrible
consequences that's just results from
their experiments their hypothesis is to
say look that the first token serves as
a kind of a a special almost like a
regularization thing where the first
token absorbs all of the attention
energy or all of the attention that is
not allocated to any other token so when
the next layer of the 15th token queries
all the things that are here right it
does so by multiplying the keys with the
values of each so its key with all the
values of each of the tokens and then it
runs a softmax across that not the key
with the value sorry the key it
multiplies its query with the keys of
each one and then it runs a softmax
across that and the softmax always needs
to sum up to one and therefore the
hypothesis is these models during
training have learned to
allocate extra like uh attention they
don't need out of that budget of one so
they have it's almost like they have a
budget of one and they have to allocate
the two different Tok tokens in the
sequence now that doesn't always add up
to one what they want to do so they have
learned to allocate that extra bit here
to just some token so they just throw it
onto some token and because the first
token is always there during training
because it has position en coding zero
right that's always there it has just
learned to allocate it to that right no
matter what the token is because it's
has a position of zero it's the first
token and because that is always there
during all of the training sequences
because of how we train it has learned
that ah I'll just dump all my attention
onto that now in practice it's going to
dump it onto the first few tokens but
still that's what the paper hypothesizes
and they demonstrated it well during
experiments um I wonder though how you
know because
I wonder maybe a secondary explanation
but maybe that's not too good because
let's say you're the 15th token right
you can look back at the third token
here but not at the first one however
the third
token contains information about the
first token due to its cache right it
can in fact look back oh wait that's the
wrong drawing I want this this was the
drawing I made for that situation so the
15th token can look back at the third
token but not at the first one yet the
third token contains information about
the the first token um so it's
conceivable that the 15th token in a
lower layer learns from the third token
about the existence of a token that has
some information that would be valuable
to the 15th token yet it it in then in
later layers it's going to try to access
that yet it can't because it can't find
it because it's not in scope this would
be an alternative explanation of why the
window detention doesn't work however
what speaks against it is that they can
actually replace the first token with
kind of any value at all like a new line
value or a null character and this the
phenomenon still occurs so the H their
hypothesis I would say is kind of solid
even though there there will be
Alternatives so so I hope you understand
a little bit the problem um that they
say exists in these models they learn to
use the zero position token as sort of a
you know like a collector of unused
energy during ATT tension and when that
zero position falls out of scope they
don't know what to do so the attention
allocation is all out of whack because
that zero position that they would
usually allocate all of that extra
attention to is no longer there and
therefore they they break and that's
what you see during their experiments so
their experiments they have have done
that and these are these are very cool
so for example these are all models that
are just trained plain language modeling
with some context length now apologize
the quality here is a bit Shady but this
is llama 2 7B
parameters um on the bottom with very
faint lines you see here um this is the
size of the KV cache and actually this
here is the maximum length that was used
during training uh maximum sequence
length the KV cache has nothing to do
with training um that's just an a thing
that people do during inference so you
can see that if you use Den attention
which means I just attend to the entire
past um then
it as I go up with the input length as
soon as I go past that line the the of
the pre-trained length um the this it
shoots up so the perplexity immediately
shoots up because it's just not been
trained on that long um if I use window
attention which is the thing where I
said okay you you just window you drop
the first one out um and you just no
longer have it in go all right at that
point as soon as the KV cache is filled
up you'll shoot up in perplexity now the
remedy to that they say is this sliding
window with recomputation that's what we
discussed initially what if I just say
well this is my new sequence now and I
just recompute that well then and you
can't see that here because it's exactly
overlapping with the red line but then
you get you stay at low perplexity which
makes sense right uh essentially you
just get a fresh sequence and you're
saying please predict the next token of
that and whether that sequence is from
the beginning of a book or from the
middle of a book you don't really care
because the language model training also
has been sort of
trained like this so there is no problem
however we mentioned you always need to
recompute now their method which they
call streaming llms achieves the exact
same perple so the lines are completely
overlapping for these models yet they
can use a cache and they can efficiently
um only recompute the latest token how
do they do that they call that attention
syncs essentially they analyze they
analyze a few models and they see okay
the hyp that's how the hypothesis
develops yeah we look at layer zero and
layer one and we kind of see a lot of
local attention scores right here so
tokens you can see so the the band here
in the middle essentially says tokens
usually attend to kind of their recent
past so token number 15 attends to token
tokens number 14 13 and 12 if well I'm
I'm good at counting um I can count and
as you go up the layers you kind of see
this pattern of uh more and more
attention being allocated to the very
first token and yeah here as you go
these are higher layers and you just see
like one long red line red means very
high attention values allocated to the
zero position tokens and so they develop
this hypothesis what if we do this what
if we just kind of keep that zero of
token around and we do this we do this
sliding window thing right here where we
just keep the caches as they were but we
always keep the zero position in the
cash we always do that and essentially
the the whole caching mechanism then
works as such there is a picture
somewhere works as such that okay if I
let's say the context length here is
eight tokens so that just fits into
token generating token 7 can look back
at all now when I generate token 8 here
I'm not going to drw Dr the first one no
I'm going to drop here the fourth one so
I have four attention sync tokens and a
sliding window of four tokens that is
local so that attention sync is always
going to stay there and the other ones I
use this sliding window technique for
both I just keep the cash around the
first ones because they're the same
tokens and for the sliding window ones
because we do that whole we don't care
about draw dropping the previous ones
away we don't care that the cash isn't
exact let's say for for that sequence
so this is going to be the new sequence
right here we are just dropping these
middle tokens away here and that's that
what they call streaming llms and these
things are what they call attention
syncs and that seems to work well I've
just shown you that actually gets you
the benefit of caching they say it's
what 22 times faster than um if you
recompute every time so that can see the
benefits of caching uh while
not in exploding your
perplexity they say they have to keep a
bunch of tokens around they have some
hypothesis around that what they also do
is they say
well is it really the case that you know
what is it about that first token or the
first tokens and they do some
experiments along that line line
especially what they do is they just
kind of replace the first tokens by new
line characters and they still get
essentially the same results so without
the attention syns very big perplexity
um but with the attention syns very
small perplexity and with the attention
syns just always being new line symbols
also very small perplexity so that tells
them it's probably not about the content
it's probably about the position en
coding of those um of those things and
yeah that's that's what leads them to
their let's say their method right here
is that once we add the attention syns
you can see that here so no attention
sync very big
perplexities uh also here with attention
syns small perplexities and sometimes
you have to add more than one
then they ask can we actually train that
so can we so this is just inference
right can we actually add some sort of
an extra token at the beginning of each
training sample to act as an attention
sync like just a null token like a
special token so that you know the the
the thing can always allocate all the
attention it wants there and the answer
is indeed yes so if you if you add a
what they call a zero sync which is they
just always add one token that's kind of
a null token without training it they do
remedy the giant perplexity so you can
see here one attention sync with the
zero sync they do remedy it but not
fully if they only have one token they
need two tokens or four tokens to
actually Remedy the situation and get to
the same let's say perplexity as a as
a um as the the vanilla model here
however if they train the model to use
these attention syns they can get the
same benefit with even a single token at
the beginning so that's just a null
token that we always append at the
beginning and you don't even have to do
much more than that you just make sure
that it's always there uh for every
training sample because then the model
will learn to allocate extra things
there and that's that's essentially the
method now one thing that I found
interesting is that what they see say
right here they say when determining the
relative distance and adding positional
information to tokens streaming llm
focuses on positions within the cache
rather than those in the original text
this distinction is crucial for
streaming llms performance for instance
if the current cach has tokens 01 2 3 6
7 8 so um let's say I'm going to
inference token 9 so this this bottom
line right here that's the situation so
we have 01 2 3 those are our attention
sync tokens and then 678 are the local
tokens around token 9 that you know so
this is the cash currently and they say
if that's the
case if we want to predict the ninth
token the positions assigned are 012 3 4
5 6 7 rather than the positions in the
original text which would be 0123 6 7 8
9 so we tell the model actually we're
not decoding the ninth token we're
decoding the seventh token and the local
tokens are 456 and the attention sings
are 1 2 3 it's all just like essentially
you just make it believe that you just
cut out the middle and you actually make
it believe that that's one continuous
piece of text
um and they say this is crucial now it's
kind of orthogonal a little bit to the
idea because so you see the zero would
be there no matter what right um the
zero position embedding is there so
therefore um that can't have an
influence but maybe this break here has
an influence right or what I also
suspect is that let's say this here
you're actually running it for a long
time this year is 50,000 and something
then the language model it might be
train to look back at certain amount or
to look back at certain tokens um
relative to its positional embeddings
and that may just break now I don't know
but you always kind of make it believe
you're within that original context
window and it's one continuous sequence
and that's where I'm asking and that's
something that I don't see in this paper
and if they've done it or if someone
else has done it
then um I apologize because I didn't see
it but that leads me to believe what if
I
do this thing right here
so the window attention but I always
just assign the positions like they
assigned the positions there uh is as
far as I understand they can change the
positioning
codings even as the cache progresses
which okay um but if they can do it here
why can't they do the same here and what
would it be because the main culprit in
the window attention is that position
zero Falls away right but if we always
renumber and always say well no actually
position zero is is right here that's
position zero right that's not position
8 um what would happen maybe I've just
overlooked something and they've
actually they have actually done
this that that is completely possible
but it seems to me if this is super
important um to have this contiguous
sequence for the streaming llm
um that starts at
zero what would happen if you do that at
the window attention again I could have
overlooked them actually doing exactly
this uh in the
experiments but I don't necessarily
recall that in any case they now uh
train so they evaluate obviously their
method so they have a bunch of
benchmarks which is really cool they
show okay we can let it it run for a
really long time it speeds it up a lot
they have their own benchmarks where
they do even multi-step interactions
that go over a long period of time and
they visualize now again this um the
trained models so the model on the left
hand side is one that we've seen before
in lower the local attention in the
lower layers and then sort of more and
more attention to the initial zero of
token in the higher layers when they
train with the sync token and by the way
if any author looks at this the I think
uh left and right here are mixed up so
I'm pretty sure right is with the sync
token and left is without the sync token
um but if they do that then you can see
even starting from layer zero attention
is you know put onto the zeroth token as
you and and that's kind of a consistent
thing so that means that um it's it kind
of it's working so the training is
working a lot of attention is put on the
zero f token and even so on Layer Two
you can see that there's still a lot of
attention on the first few tokens right
which is why they have to include
multiple attention syns but if you
actually train with an attention sync uh
that much faster consolidates to just
the initial just the zeroth attention
sync token so I would say the hypothesis
is pretty solid the um
experiments show that the hypothesis is
probably has probably some truth to it
uh the solution is pretty intuitive I
would say and and solid and it's totally
workable this can totally be built into
today's inference Frameworks and yeah
extensive experiments and yeah that's
that's essentially all it's a neat paper
it's it's cool to read if you're if
you're newer and want to read an more
it's very very well written and yeah
that's all I have to say uh let me know
what you think about this the only thing
that I can still think is that I was
thinking of this model called Big Bird
um so big big bird that kind of did the
same thing but for bidirectional
attention so their attention Matrix
essentially looked like okay we have
this band here this diagonal band and
then we also have always attention to
the initial tokens and then also some
random attention in between and there so
this is more like burp style models
right for embeddings and stuff like this
um their reasoning was you know the
first tokens are probably kind of
important for stuff and therefore we
always include the first tokens and not
ever about soft Max or anything like
this and there are some things that are
conceivably different for example in bir
directional attention all the tokens can
actually attend to the first token and
the first token can attend to all the
tokens so they are just another let's
say uh token that can attend to stuff
and it's perfectly conceivable that
actually the semantics of the initial
tokens of a sequence like the beginning
of a sentence like what where or
something like you know like the first
first word of a sentence is or the first
words are sometimes quite
informative um and also I think during
training of these bird style models and
so on it was much more the case that um
every single example had the context
essentially filled up and there wasn't
too much padding as far as I understand
but maybe not Maybe not maybe one should
go back look at big bird and say Hey
what if we you know just kind of replace
the first these these token of global
attention here with some new lines and
what if we actually train with these
attention syns and uh yeah that would be
interesting to find out and maybe it
might revise an old old work and maybe
it might revise old work and gain new
insights into why a model like big bird
has had a higher performance than for
example bird all right that's it for me
I'll see you around bye-bye